AS Global Elites continue to reel from
the election of right-wing libertarian
Javier mle in Argentina pundits are
racking their brains over how it
happened how did mle do it what
differentiates the election in Argentina
from elections in say Brazil or the
United States or anywhere in between was
it mes stance on social issues was it
Argentina's presently soaring inflation
was it his blunt talk was it his funny
hair I've got a simpler answer two words
paper
ballots last month the Buenos AAS Herald
reported that City residents would be
required to vote on paper ballots after
electronic voting machines caused all
sorts of chaos and confusion in the
primaries leading to a federal judge
striking them down and returning to
voters the right to elect candidates the
oldfashioned way what's the argument for
electronic voting the only argument is
that it makes the process faster and
more efficient except it doesn't because
the machines break and then the pipes
burst and then vote counting takes days
and weeks even especially when the vote
count starts to look bad for
liberals paper ballots gave argentinians
their answer on election day it was an
answer that the liberal Elites don't
like it was an answer that the
Argentinian people might not have gotten
had computers allowed the count to drag
on behind an opaque electronic veil of
secrecy the only advantage that
electronic voting has over paper ballots
is that it makes it much much easier for
Bad actors to steal
elections Argentina was right to get rid
of it American conservatives better take
note if we want that result down south
to Herald good things for us next year
I'm Michael nolles this is the Michael
nlls
[Music]
show welcome back to the show this
episode's brought to you by jus C SK go
to jus.com noes to get an incredible
holiday discount on their most popular
package also quick reminder that the
best deal of the year was here 50% off
all new dailyware plus annual membership
daily.com subscribe right now to
join Gavin Nome potentially the Democrat
Presidential nominee currently the
governor of California doing his best
Patrick bitman impression every day he
just accidentally admitted that LGBT
activism is obscene we'll get to that in
just a moment first though the man who
currently has the job Joe Biden is
losing a lot of support his numbers are
absolutely in the in the doldrums he
seemed to endorse Gavin Newsome for
president the other day he said this guy
is really good he could do anything he
could even have the job I'm running for
h and a lot of Democrats I think were
listening to that and saying yes he's
certainly good Joe you're right but it's
worth remembering even as everyone
appears to abandon Joe Biden that he
does still have one really prominent
endorsement and that is the endorsement
of Osama bin Laden people forget this
because Osama Bin Laden's endorsement of
Joe Biden came from a letter that was
discovered after the raid on Bin Laden's
compound in Pakistan and abadabad at but
in that
letter U Osama said that groups the
Jihadi groups will remain on the lookout
for Obama or
Petraeus the American General and
director of the CIA the reason for
concentrating on them is that o Obama is
the head of infidelity and killing him
automatically will make Biden take over
the presidency for the remainder of the
term as it is the norm over there Biden
is totally unprepared for that post
which will lead the us into a crisis as
for Petraeus he is the man of the hour
in this last year of the war and killing
him would alter the war's path so please
ask brother ilas to send to me the steps
he has taken into that work okay
I think the letter is real I think the
endorsement is real and I think Osama
Bin Laden's point about Joe Biden is
absolutely correct and I think that
point was proven right over the past few
years of Biden's presidency Bin Laden
very evil man had lots of crazy ideas
floating around his head but even a
stopped clock is right twice a
day and he was right about Biden Joe
Biden's presidency has led America into
crisis
three years ago we had peace in the
Middle East we had a flourishing economy
before covid we had uh our allies around
the world stepping up to the plate
actually paying for some of their own
defense we had trade deals being
renegotiated we had at least for a Time
immigration declining illegal
immigration declining until the Deep
State gummed up the works and and
hindered Donald Trump from from
diminishing
that things were pretty good things are
pretty good
remember and then Joe Biden took over
and it's amazing how quickly things can
fall to
pot proving Osama Bin Laden's prediction
correct which might actually help Joe
Biden here because don't forget
Zoomers are flocking to Bin Laden on Tik
Tok they've discovered Osama Bin Laden's
letter to America and they they're
discovering this as as though for the
first time and saying oh wow Osama was
totally right and we covered it on the
show a few days ago so who knows maybe
this is all maybe the Osama endorsement
was actually leaked by the Biden
campaign to win him support among the
Zoomers that would be
5D that would be I think nine or 10 D
chess which because I agree that Biden
is a complete train Wack he probably is
not capable of playing but who knows
that might be the effect of it now
speaking of attacks on Joe
Biden I I have to sort of defend him a
little bit Joe Biden went viral
yesterday again for supposedly making
weird creepy comments to a little girl
here it is thank you thank you thank you
and I love your ears I love them they're
really cool what's your name Catherine
Catherine what a beautiful name that's
my mommy's name well nice to see how old
are you
six okay so the way this is being
reported and going viral is Joe Biden
compliments a six-year-old's body and
then he creepily asks if she's 17 and
he's a big creep and he is kind of
creepy I'm not denying that at all he's
got the weird thing about sniffing girls
hair and there's the weird stuff in the
Ashley Biden diary and it's he's is
weird is a weird I'm not denying that
but this video is not an example of that
creepiness it's an example of another
character flaw with Joe Biden but I
don't think he's letching on this little
girl
when he's complimenting her ears I don't
think that's him you know objectifying
her and and when he's asking if she's 17
I don't think he's trying to take her
out on a
date the the character flaw that this
reveals about Joe Biden is not his
lasciviousness it's his absolute oily
gladh handing simpering backs slapping
politician empty suited that's what it
is Joe Biden has no answer on any issues
I don't think he has any particular
convictions on any political issues
either but what he's really good at is
backs slapping people and joking around
and making making them feel like he's
good old Uncle Joe so what he's doing
here he's putting on a show for the
other people in the room it's not like
he's having a private moment with this
little girl he's putting on a show for
all these adults in the room hey there
little girl you're you're so nicel
looking hey there how old are you 17 no
I'm just joking anyway it's it's like
when a politician kisses babies
that's what this is for and for Joe
Biden who's 700 years old now you know
if you're under 40 you're a baby to him
so it's what it is and it's his best
shot at getting elected if Joe Biden has
ever been elected president it will be
it will have been
because he is really good at backs
slapping and simpering and that that's
what's going on here the hair stuff is
weird but I just think it's a distinct
issue and I want to be fair okay I don't
want to just be a total hack all the
time I want to defend Joe Biden so that
I can criticize him further speaking of
sexual impropriety Gavin Nome the
governor of California just
accidentally said that LGBT behavior is
obscene he tweeted out this few days ago
he tweeted out this article from the new
Republic and he said a city in Tennessee
has banned being gay in public this is
just the beginning we have to call this
out wow a city in Tennessee banned being
gay in public what's that I looked and
the city is right near me it's Murphy's
Boro they banned being gay in public
whatever that means well hold on what
did they actually ban I looked in I
pulled up the
article the city passed an ordinance
back in June nome's just tweeting about
it now in November back in June they
tweeted out or they they passed an
ordinance Banning indecent Behavior
including indecent exposure public
indecency lwd Behavior nudity or sexual
conduct in other words the governor of
California has just
equated being gay with indecent and
obscene Behavior Oopsy Daisy G Gavin
Nome has just made the argument that the
most staunch right-wing social
conservatives have been making for a
long time what the libs have tried to
argue is no this kind of behavior in
public is not obscene no the pride
parades they're totally familyfriendly
no the drag queen Story Hour it's just
nice fellas wearing silly costumes just
innocently reading books to little kids
the conservatives have said n man The
Pride parades are and they belong if
anywhere they
belong they certainly don't belong on
Main Street and and the drag queen Story
Hour stuff it's a bunch
of
who just get a kick out
of that's really what it's about and
it's and Gavin Nome the Democrat just
came out and he's like hey those
conservatives they're totally right oops
that's what we call a Freudian slip
where of course uh one says one thing
but means one's mother now when you want
to hire people for jobs that are better
at them than say uh the governor of
California you got to check out zi
recruiter right now go to
ziprecruiter.com with Thanksgiving just
a few days away I wanted to show some
gratitude to some of the people on my
team to Mr Davies and Professor Jacob
for producing our show to Danny producer
Danny for editing the show to the great
famous Tessa for keeping me on top of
everything I have to do every day takes
a team of amazing people to make this
show successful just like it takes an
amazing team to make any business
successful if you're hiring you need to
find the best people for your team you
need Z recruiter right now you can try
it for free at z recruiter.com
kwes z recruiter uses smart technology
to scan thousands of resumés to find the
most qualified people for your job zip
recruiter lets the most qualified people
know that they are a great match and
encourages them to apply zip recruiter
is trusted by millions in fact over 3.8
million businesses have come to zip
recruiter for their hiring needs see for
yourself why so many business owners are
hiring based on zip recruiter four out
of five employers who post on zip
recruiter get a quality candidate within
the first day I would be very grateful
if you would go to this exclusive web
address to try zip recruiter for free
ziprecruiter.com
ziprecruiter.com KW ZipRecruiter the
smartest way to hire speaking of
undermining the liberal narrative
there's a story I bet you've seen it
going around that Israel the state of
Israel has arrested an NBC
journalist for expressing public support
of Hamas and the palestin Liberation
movement and what you're going to hear
from the liberal Defenders of the state
of Israel is that this is not
true Israel has not arrested a
journalist this it's totally different
this person is for some whatever reason
this person is not a real journalist and
they were siding with the terrorists and
that's why we arrested them and it's not
arresting
journalists but that's not true the
state of Israel arrested a journalist
this person not like a you know wasn't
Walter kronite but this person was a
freelancer working for
NBC I think it's totally defensible but
it's not defensible from a liberal
perspective it's only defensible from a
conservative perspective it's only
defensible from the perspective that
there's no such thing as totally neutral
balanced journalism with without any
political partisan leaning
whatsoever it's only defensible if you
reject the liberal notion that we just
need total absolute free speech at all
times everywhere with no standards
whatsoever man and we can never in any
way have standards or or Norms of
decency man it's it's only defensible if
you adopt the view that I adopted in my
book speechless controlling words
controlling Minds which at the time
hello where's my bell where's my bell
guys good grief I don't they're already
on vacation for
Thanksgiving at the time I wrote that
book which now was what two years
ago a lot of conservatives were
embracing the liberal View that that
journalists are the esteemed fourth
estate and they are above reproach and
the journal we have to defend the
journalists at all costs and we need
total free speech at all no we we
need we need proper speech Protections
in line with the American tradition in
line with the best practices of our
civilization but we can't
pretend that societies are not entitled
to any standards whatsoever we can't
pretend that we don't we're not allowed
to have uh standards against indecent
behavior and obscenity that's the point
we were just making with Gavin
Newsome in this
case the state of Israel sees this
freelance journalist promoting Hamas
Israel's sworn enemy against which
Israel is currently conducting a war and
they're saying oh yeah we're not going
to allow the propagandists for our enemy
terrorists who are killing civilians and
who currently have hostages in Gaza
we're not going to let this propagandist
just go about spreading wartime
propaganda we're going to arrest this
person and then NBC fired the person
and now there's one less propagandist on
the
street but I think that's totally
defensible if I were in the Israeli
government that's exactly the sort of
thing I would do they're a war it's an
existential War as they describe it it's
a it's another war of
independence but don't look at me and
tell me that the facts are not what they
are don't try to save the liberal
narrative as many on the center left and
even on the center right are trying to
do right now no we're admitting here
there's no such thing as totally neutral
journalism we're admitting that the
distinction between journalism and
propaganda is a little bit blurry
sometimes we're admitting that societies
have the right to standards and norms we
admitting that at times of War
particularly existential War some of
those civil liberties that we all enjoy
sometimes get a little bit curtailed
because if they were not to be total a
little bit curtailed then you would lose
the totality of those civil rights
protections don't liberals don't urinate
on my leg and tell me that it's raining
this is a this is a great teachable
moment for the realities of speech in
society and and it's a great opportunity
to go get speechless controlling words
controlling Minds available now
whereever find books are sold number one
National bestseller thank you very
much now I want to go back to Newsome we
took a little
break from Nome to go to Hamas now we're
going to go back to Nome Gavin Newsome
is running TV ads Gavin usam who's
totally not running for president
remember he supports Joe Biden he's not
running but he is running TV ads against
Ron de santis ahead of the Nome DeSantis
totally not presidential
debate wanted by order of Governor Ron
de santis any woman who has an abortion
after 6 weeks and any doctor who gives
her care will be guilty of a felony
abortion after 6 weeks will be
punishable by up to 5 years in prison
even though many women don't even know
they're pregnant at 6 weeks that's not
Freedom it's Ronda Sis's
Florida campaign for democracy pack is
responsible for the contest of this
advertising no no candidate I love the
the disclaimer here not authorized by
any candidate or candidates committee
even though who narrated the ad the ad
was narrated by Gavin Nome why is he
running ads against as santis right now
well they got this debate coming up this
is the true undercard presidential
debate and they got the debate coming up
and Nome wants to Prime the public to
say that he won the
debate he's just trying to get in his
opponent's head before the debate and
why did he pick this issue he picked
this issue because he wants to prime a
split between the DeSantis and the Trump
camps he wants to Rally up the most
left-wing
base which supports infanticide but he
also wants to Prime this split between
the Trump and DeSantis camps because
Trump was asked about desantis's
abortion policy in Florida and Trump
reflexively criticized it now I don't
think Trump criticized it because Trump
is pro-abortion I think Trump is the
most pro-life president we've ever had
in my lifetime and he's responsible for
getting roie Wade overruled after 50
years but Trump reflexively attacks
whatever his opponents do and so when
DeSantis did something very very good in
Florida which is protect life to a large
degree what was it a six-week abortion
Manan Trump attacks that he would have
attacked anything that Dan santis did
but this puts conservatives in a pickle
because
it's a it's a wedge between the Trump
and Des santis camps even if everyone
agrees on pro-life it's just another way
to get in there and it's a reminder that
Gavin Nome is a very very clever
politician he's really smart in fact
after DeSantis accepted the debate and
it was clear that this was going to go
ahead nuum mocked DeSantis and he said
this is a joke Dan santis is crazy for
accepting this debate because it shows
that he's not focused he's supposed to
be debating the other Republican
presidential candidates he shouldn't be
debating
me implicit I think was that the debate
is good for Nome because it elevates
Newsome to the level of a presidential
candidate if Nome could have debated
Trump I'm sure he would have Trump's not
going to debate anybody so okay he's
going to debate DeSantis next best thing
but then he mocks Dan santis he says
what is De Dan santis debating me for
I'm not even officially running for
president I'm just the governor of
California guy's totally unprepared he's
just getting in his head ahead of this
debate
that the point of which I can't even
quite understand here I I get it for
Nome and I guess the point for disantis
is that he wants to be seen as a fighter
and he's going to beat up the libs but I
think there are better ways to do that
which actually B ramaswami just showed a
few days ago first though when you want
to look good you got to check out Jus
cell right now go to genucell.com I've
got a Christmas gift idea that is sure
to make you the the hero of the Season
we all know that the holidays get a
little hectic the shopping the cooking
the never- ending list of things to do
well fear not because I've discovered a
gift that is not just thoughtful it's
downright transformative that is the
gift of genell skincare from now until
Christmas genell's most popular package
has a special discount just for our
listeners at J cell.com treat yourself
and your loved ones to the absolute best
skincare in the world those troubling
forehead wrinkles Fine Lines skin
redness and yes even a sagging jawline
will disappear right before you rise
with jus cell's most popular collection
Jus cell promises immediate effects
you'll see results in less than 12 hours
guaranteed or your money back Jus cell
made Christmas come early this year they
sent down a ton of products for our
office and everyone looks way hotter now
than they did before Simply the Best out
there go check out jell you deserve to
look and feel your best this season go
to jus.com to get this incredible
Christmas discount every order today is
instantly upgraded to free express
shipping jus.com can Wes today disantis
is in in a tough spot right now as I've
said from the beginning I won't belabor
the point he always was in a basically
impossible position because the best
thing to recommend him is the best
campaign pitch for disantis is that he's
the better version of trump bigger
better faster stronger he's more focused
more of a policy Wong
whatever uh that argument only works if
Dan santis can pull a significant number
of trump voters so far he has not been
able to do that so then the second best
argument for disantis is well he's not
Donald Trump so he'll be the alternative
to Donald Trump but the never trumpers
some of them like Dan santis some of
them don't like Dan santis because they
view Dan santis as a little too trumpy a
little too willing to to use government
power so a lot of those people who
really want an alternative to Trump
they're looking at Nikki Haley they were
looking at Tim Scott before Tim Scott
dropped out of the race they're looking
at other
candidates so this hurts desantis's
polling he's still the number number two
guy in the race but right now even in
Florida University of North Florida poll
shows Trump at 60% in Florida that's D
santis state where he's currently
Governor he's currently up on Dan santis
by 39 points that puts Dan santis at 21
and Dan santis is still way up on his
next nearest opponent Nikki Haley but
who cares if you're looking at 60 versus
21 versus
6 it doesn't really matter the santis
could have 30 points it still wouldn't
he would still be way behind Trump and
nobody wants to be number two the other
thing that's going to hurt D santis here
again I hate hate to be the bearer of
bad news for for people who like and I I
really like the santis too I'm not
endorsing in the primary but I really
like the guy I think he would be a
perfectly good president I think he's
been an excellent governor of Florida
but what you're going to start to see
happening is the momentum building now
that it looks as though Dan santis is
not going to go the distance some people
are going to start to look at someone
like Haley but other people who were
sitting on the fence are now just going
to endorse Trump so you you've seen
Sarah Sanders for instance who obviously
she worked for Trump she's been very
supportive of trump but she said I'm not
really going to endorse yet she just
endorsed in the primary endorsed Trump
you're seeing people who had previously
endorsed to sandas in Florida five of
them Florida uh Representatives flip and
they vote they now endorse Trump you
were seeing now Governor Abbott in Texas
who was sitting on the fence he wasn't
going to pick a candidate he's just come
out now endorses Trump we need a
president who's going to secure the
Border we need a president who's going
to restore Law and Order in the United
States of America not letting these
criminals run ransack over the stores
that you see images of almost night
nightly we need a president who's going
to restore World Peace as opposed to
this outbreak of warfare under Joe Biden
we need Donald J Trump back as our
president of the United States of
America I'm here today to officially
Proclaim my endorsement for Donald J
Trump to be president of the United
States of America again there he is okay
so you're seeing
consolidation and that will probably
continue I'm not saying to sandis is out
of the race yet but the question is what
is going to change the momentum here the
answer previously was the debates just
wait until the debates and then that's
going to change the momentum didn't
happen a lot of people were saying Trump
should show up to the first debate
you'll recall some of us said that while
we might like Trump to show up to the
debate if I were advising the Trump
campaign I would say don't show up to
the debate because it can only hurt you
it can't really help you it's very very
high risk very little potential reward
then some people said okay he won't show
up to the first debate but he will show
up to the second debate I was skeptical
of that too I said we'll see if the
strategy Works strategy works so he
doesn't have to show up to any of them
so now the debates aren't going to make
it a difference so so now what's going
to change the momentum well for disantis
he's got this Hail Mary pass which is
the the debate with Gavin Nome if that
debate goes really well maybe that
affects the race if the debate goes
poorly for desandis that might affect
the race too in that it might it might
wrap it up even more quickly what about
the other candidates the vake has a
different strategy the vake is not going
out and debating prominent left-wing
politicians the vake is going out you
want to get back to our Hamas story you
want to get back to the real nature of
Journalism V is going out and he's
attacking the most notable and prominent
opposition leaders of all in the United
States namely the left-wing media that
language they live like Vermin do you
believe that that is as your uh
Republican colleague Chris chrisa said
Neo-Nazi rhetoric this is a classic
mainstream media move pick some
individual phrase of Donald Trump focus
on literally that word without actually
interrogating the substance of what's at
issue the word was chosen middle of a
cultural war in this
country it's actually describing a
series of behaviors you have antifa and
other related groups that have been
burning down cities for the last 3 years
in this country would you describe them
violating the rule of law we have an
invasion on our Southern border we have
millions of people crossing our Southern
border let's talk about the substance of
why we have to recognize that we're not
in ordinary times the vocabulary of the
verban or not is not what's important
well I haven't used that language so you
can look at my my track record on the
campaign Trail I talk about the issues
we all talk about them differently but
what I'm not going to do is play some
game of focusing on some word that
somebody else said without ignoring
entirely the substance of what we're
actually talking about a border crisis
of historic proportion economic
stagnation we haven't seen in 50 years a
national identity crisis and a loss of
national pride in the Next Generation
that's potentially existential for this
country let's talk about our dependence
on China today we're actually talking
about Shan ping picking on Donald
Trump's word vermin to talk about that
status quo you know what's Vermin what's
running around San Francisco on a given
day before Gavin Nome cleaned it up on a
dime to roll out the red carpet for
xianping if he could do that for xiin
Ping he could have done it on an
ordinary day this is a good strategy
this is what we want to see we want to
see our candidates own the lives look at
mle down in
Argentina Javier mle who is an eon you
know he he's a
professor but Javier mle is also a TV
personality Javier mle is also a guy
with a silly haircut a guy who dances up
on stage and what does he do he gives
these interviews where he just
belligerently attacks the left and
people gobble it up that's what we want
to see and I don't think that's
necessarily wrong or base the libs run
the show they run every institution
they've run them into the ground they
obviously despise us they Express their
contempt for us at every turn and so
yeah we want to see some conservatives
give it right back to
him and what's the most effective way to
do that you could do it by debating the
governor of California it probably be a
pretty good
debate but the way you're you're most
likely going to get that that that
minute clip that goes viral is in one of
these exchanges online so I think V is
very sharp he's a very strong candidate
especially for having virtually zero
name recognition before he entered the
race the question now is can he close
the
gap I I don't really think there are
enough CNN hits in the
world for that alone to be what closes
the Gap but it could serve him pretty
well in the race and especially if Trump
does end up being the nominee it could
position him well for a cabinet position
or or something else or if Trump is out
of the race he might even have a shot at
the at the title
meanwhile Trump says we got to end all
this Trump uh tweets out or he doesn't
tweet it out he trth he truths it out he
says great polls just released best ever
Harvard Harris Trump 67% Des
sanctimonious 9% bird brain 8 is that
haey sorry I got I I've been a little
behind on my trump nicknames this cycle
bird brain is okay 8% ramaswami 5%
Christie dead in the water a total Los
interesting ramas Swami and Christie
don't even Christie who who Trump
doesn't seem to like very much they
don't get nicknames though though Trump
does call Christie a total loser dead in
the water Trump UPS 7 to 10% on crooked
Joe Biden RNC must save money on lowest
ever ratings debates use it against the
Democrats to stop the steel if not
revamp the RNC now that last line is the
key here because R McDaniel who runs the
Republican National Committee only has a
job today because Donald Trump is
willing to allow her to keep that
post virtually every other candidate is
calling for her to step down and major
GOP figures and major conservative
movement figures are calling for her to
step down Trump so far has said well she
can keep her job
maybe but if she doesn't end these
debates maybe we got to revamp the whole
thing and let's say you hate Donald
Trump as you know I don't hate Donald
Trump I rather like the man but but
let's say you just hate the guy or let's
say you don't hate the guy but you just
don't want him to be the nominee again
or however you
feel can you really disagree with him on
this point that the debates serve no
other purpose than to waste time and
money resources that could be spent
fighting the Democrats can you really
disagree with that
point you might say well the voters have
a right to hear the candidates
debate yeah maybe the voters don't seem
to care because Trump's refusal to show
up has not hurt him in the polls it's if
anything his polls have gone
up well sure but it's it's disrespectful
to the voters yeah again the voters
don't seem to feel that disrespect they
don't seem to care at all well I just
think we ought to have more debates
why because that's what we have done in
the past yeah in the past we haven't had
primaries like this this is a totally
different primary because For the First
time in 100 years you have a candidate
who was the president running for a
non-consecutive second term so it's
totally different you can't say well
that's what we did in
2008 so what's the point you might hate
him you might hate Donald Trump for
being right about this point but I don't
think that anyone seriously can deny
that he is right here there's no if the
debates were going to change the
momentum of the race wouldn't they have
done that in the first three
debates but the momentum of the race has
not changed at all in the slightest look
back at the RCP Real Clear Politics
polling average so not even just one
poll or two polls but the average of all
the polls weighted in a pretty serious
way going back all the way to the very
start of this campaign what was it 15 16
months
ago nothing has changed at all candidate
goes up a little blip goes down a little
blip that's about that's
it so what's the
point and if they don't cut this out I
mean I I'm not going to go so far as to
call for the RNC chairman to step down
but if you're Ron and McDaniel right now
you've got to take this very seriously I
do not blame the RNC chairman for any
disappointments that may have occurred
in recent election Cycles I think I
think it's cheap and easy to blame the
head of the RNC I don't think the head
of the RNC matters all that much I think
the candidates matter I think the timing
matters I think the way that the
elections are conducted whether it's
hackable electronic voting machines or
paper ballots I think that matters I
don't really think whoever sits as the
chairman of the RNC does all that much
but if you're Ron McDaniel and you're
only prominent Defender right now is
saying hey lady shape up or you're out
you probably got to take that pretty
seriously so putting aside these
elections for a moment moving on to more
consequential matters the Pentagon is
you want to talk about wasting money on
nonsense the
Pentagon is about to finish spending
$270 million on Dei initiatives which
we'll get to in one second first though
my favorite comment yesterday is from
Joshua
M MK5 RR says bring xiin ping to Philly
man this place needs some help bad I
totally agree whoever wins the
presidential election whether it's Trump
or disantis whether it's Biden or Nome I
whoever
wins that person needs to promise within
the first 100 days to bring xiin ping on
a national tour of the United States all
the major cities we will clean up these
cities for the first time in decades
it'll be really great then s sheing home
I don't want him to stay here too long
but just long enough to clean up all of
the cities that sounds terrific the best
deals of the year are happening right
now and yes that includes 50% off new
dailywire plus annual memberships but
there's so much more to check out during
this Black Friday sale go to
dailywire.com blackf Friday to check out
all of the best deals including up to 70
70% off apparel the famous leftist tears
Tumblr books and much more at the daily
wire shop top it off with a huge deal on
the best game to play with your friends
and family this holiday season that is
the yes or no game by Yours Truly start
filling up your carts before these deals
disappear shop all of the Black Friday
deals right now dailywire.com blackf
Friday do not miss out on the best deals
of the year the
dod the Department of
Defense is now looking at spending $270
million in taxpayer funds to advance
diversity equity and inclusion and
accessibility there's a new one it's
deia now from fiscal years 20122 to
so you had de IIA spending in fiscal
year 2022 was 68 million bucks then it
jumped to 86.5 million bucks in 20123
then it jumped to 114 14.7 million bucks
in the initial request for 2024 so you
look at at 270 million bucks why for
what for what purpose does that
serve it advances political correctness
it advances the liberal agenda it it
advances wokeness or whatever word you
want to
use it in no way makes our military
better able to fight
Wars how does diversity help our
military fight Wars it doesn't doesn't
at all Unity helps militaries fight Wars
diversity does not Equity how does
Equity help we don't want equity in the
military we want the strongest baddest
toughest craziest most disciplined guys
to go out there and kill our enem
you don't want Equity you don't want a
leveling of anything you want you want
Excellence inclusion
inclusion I don't want inclusion in the
military I want exclusion I want all the
people who are weak all the people who
are unsure about our objectives all the
people who are a little lukewarm on
patriotism I want them all out of the
military I don't want inclusion in the I
want severe exclusion because I want the
very very best
accessibility even I'm I'm all for
making life easier for people who have
diff particular difficulties in civilian
life not in the military I want I want
people who are in the absolute toughest
baddest fighting shape in the
military
listen I don't I don't run a 4-minute
mile all right I've never I've never
focused as much as I probably should on
physical strength okay I know I look
like a hulking glistening aonis it's
just how I was born it's not for any
working out I'm not I I probably am not
in fighting shape to go fight a war
today that's
fine okay if I were drafted I'd try to
I'd try to make it work but I'm not I
don't think that the military is for
everybody I want the toughest baddest
guys who are going to fulfill the only
objective of the military which is to
protect us which entails killing our
enemies okay that's it 270 million bucks
not only wasted the way this is being
reported is this moneyy is being wasted
it's not it's even worse than that it's
money that is being spent to make us
weaker how pathetic is
that now speaking of money grabs Snoop
Diggity Doo
as you know said that he was going to
give up
smoke and when this ad came he posted it
to Instagram he said hey I'm giving up
smoke please respect my privacy Snoop
and I said hold
up all the fellas who be saying he's
soft Snoop don't play he's going to rock
it until the wheels fall off I thought
that we might actually be preparing for
a new episode so if Snoop was going to
give up the sin spinach maybe he'd move
on to
puffing something else for those who are
listening right now I am in fact tapping
the Mayflower
box but it turns out Snoop had another
trick up his sleeve here it is I have an
announcement I'm giving up
smoke I know what you thinking Snoop
smoke is kind of your whole thing but
I'm done with it done with the coughin
and my clothes smelling all sticky igy
I'm going
smokeless solo throw fixed fire they
took out the smoke oh
clever Snoop is there obviously High
toasting a
marshmallow it's clever I love even the
commentary of the ad where he just looks
at you and you it's so officiously lame
that it's actually cool and funny again
goes clever I'm going smokeless for this
fire pit that I have
outside that dirty dog he got us again
now maybe I should send him a box of
Mayflower anyway you know maybe it's
just an
opportunity okay there's a note I wanted
to read someone wrote into
me yesterday two days ago a listener
wrote in and some when I talk about dogs
you know I'm not a huge I'm not I'm not
it's not that I'm a dog person it's not
that I'm a cat person I say I'm a people
person and I wrote in or rather I I
mentioned this story about how pets
don't make people happier there's a
study I think studies are mostly bogus
but when they back up my points I cite
them and the study said actually you
think pets are going to make you happier
they really don't pet owners and non-pet
owners are bet equally happy and I said
this is important because there's no
substitute for for
Humanity you maybe you can't have a
child maybe you're infertile a lot of
people deal with that it's a very tough
thing to deal with maybe you're not
called to marriage maybe you're not
called to Parenthood but you should be
involved with people you can be called
to a kind of spiritual Parenthood like
being you're a godmother Godfather maybe
you're a priest or otherwise
religious but you need to be involved
with people dogs aren't going to cut it
now I got this letter say Michael I'm a
45-year-old mom of dog that completely
agrees with your opinion regarding dog
moms not dog parents as the men rarely
use the moniker I fully fell for the lie
that as a woman I could have it all I
graduated college with a BS in nursing
and an officer's Commission in the Air
Force thank you for your service I had
every intention of seeing the world
finding the perfect man and being able
to work full-time while raising my
children but thanks to chick flicks and
the feminist worm in my ear I kept
looking for the next best thing and
missed what was right in front of me I
fled from a wonderful man who wanted to
marry me because I had come to believe I
could do better wrong I bounced from man
to man always wanting something more I
lost out on my one opportunity to have a
family and suffered the pain and loss of
having to abort an ectopic pregnancy due
to complications associated with
endometriosis
even though it was a non-viable
pregnancy I grieve the loss of that
little zygote every day as a result of
my struggles I became closed off and
unable to accept love from men I remain
single to this day although I have come
to understand my mistakes and accept my
culpability I know I am also a casualty
of the leftist feminist ideology I pray
every day for healing and guidance from
God for he is truly the only one who can
make me whole and worthy of Love since
I'm single and alone I've chosen a dog
as a companion for now it was either
that or cats and I refused to be a cat
lady I also deal with pts for my
military service and was graced with the
gift of my Aussie doodle puppy two years
ago while I love him dearly and I'm so
grateful to have a watcher while I pee I
do my very best to avoid the dog mom
stereotype I also urge every woman I
talk to to avoid my mistakes and accept
that having it all is impossible It's a
cruel joke played by the left and
perpetuated by Hollywood and the media
it's so important to keep telling women
that there is always a sacrifice when we
try to have it all and the real question
is what are we willing to sacrifice I
grew up with a working mom mom and dad I
can say with no hesitation I would have
preferred my mom was home more any child
that has a working mom is losing out on
a very important Bond and it will shape
them in unimaginable ways and forever
harm their life I'm fortunate enough to
still have my mom and dad together and
in my life but many adult children don't
it's the truth that the only thing I
want from my parents is their time and
Company money is important for survival
but you are so right when you say a
childless life is not worth the small
increase in income I'm living proof I
would give up that 8% and more to be
able to go back and fix the dumbest
mistake of my life I've tried to be a
parental figure by sponsoring a child
through Compassion International I write
letters to her and try to be a good
influence but it is a pale imitation of
what I should have I have a 16-year-old
nephew who is a budding artist and I try
to nurture his talent but he lives far
away and it's difficult to communicate
with him I take solace that my nephew is
was homeschooled by my sister-in-law and
I tell her she's a hero every chance I
get I'm so worried about the future of
younger generations and how poorly
they've been raised many of whom have
been raised by public school teachers
have warped and poison their minds have
become they've become confused about
everything and are ripe for the plucking
by leftist Propaganda and activism I
encourage you to share my story and keep
talking about the importance of faith in
God family children and committed
couples these are the only things that
will save us from the abyss of leftist
ideology and agenda and then she goes on
to thank me for the show uh really good
letter thank you for your letter sorry
for the difficulties you have faced but
I I think it was really articulate and
you you have you are giving people the
grace of uh teaching by example of the
things you've learned really good lesson
okay it's Tuesday we got to get to it
the show continues now you don't want to
miss it become a member use code NOS
canw a check out for two months free on
all annual
[Music]
plans